do you remember how inescapable pop punk
was in the early 2000s blink 182 was all
over mtv the band's drummer travis
barker even had a reality tv show pete
wentz a fallout boy was frequently on
the cover of j-14 simple plan even made
a cameo in an olsen twins movie
eventually fans and bands grew up and
pop punk faded from the limelight in the
early 2010s fast forward to today
pop punk is back and gen z is reviving
the scene musicians like willow meet me
at the altar
kingship and kenny hoopla have taken the
torch even gen z artists outside the
genre like olivia rodrigo and the kid
leroy are borrowing from pop punk
resulting in viral chart toppers in this
video we're going to dig into just how
gen z is leading a pop punk revival and
make sure you stay to the end where we
try to create our own pop punk inspired
tune
okay so what does pop punk even mean
well it's basically an offshoot of punk
that drifts away from the heavy and
aggressive toward a melodic and pop
sound some say the ramones were the
first pop punk band but the descendants
became the blueprint for pop punk in
1982 with their lp milo goes to college
[Music]
[Applause]
descendants drummer bill stevenson cited
his influences as the kinks the seeds
the ramones and the early beatles
without the descendants bands like blink
182 who pushed pop punk into the
mainstream may have never existed in
2016 mark hoppus of blink 182 said the
first song of the descendants i heard
was silly girl and it blew my mind that
just changed the trajectory of my life
forever when pop punk first emerged in
the late 80s it wasn't an immediate
commercial success then in 1994 that
changed when green day became an
overnight sensation with their album
dookie which went on to win a grammy in
1995.
[Music]
following green day
bands like blink 182 newfound glory and
some 41 began to take over the radio
link 182 became one of pop punk's
biggest names after the success of their
1999 album enema of the state the songs
had a coming-of-age feel fast and
driving drums were paired with a mix of
goofy but melancholic lyrics
[Music]
i was kind of like a closeted fan of pop
punk for sure when i was a teenager pop
punk was like the cool music to listen
to
as the mid-2000s approached mainstream
radio started to shift from rock and pop
toward b and hip hop with artists like
kanye and rihanna
[Applause]
during this shift a new generation of
pop punk fans found an audience with the
youth artists like paramore fallout boy
my chemical romance and panic at the
disco these bands signaled a shift in
the sound of pop punk as they took
influence from the emo and scene
subcultures their new moodier version of
the genre started to blur the lines
defining pop punk
were these bands pop punk were they emo
pop well there's some debate on where
these bands fit in these artists use
characteristics from both genres in
their music
[Music]
during this time many of these
successful pop punk and emo pop bands
performed at the vans warped tour warb's
tour began in 1995 and started as a
skate punk music tour with lots of third
wave sky musicians featured in the
lineup
the tour soon morphed into a
predominantly pop punk and metalcore
focused tour during the 2010s pop punk's
popularity began to fade
possibly because mainstream radio began
to favor hip hop possibly because the
teens that listen to the genre began to
grow up or maybe the bands found it
difficult to adapt to the times haley
williams said the scene during the early
2000s was a lot of internalized sexism
and even when you were lucky enough to
meet other bands who were kind and
respectful
there was other
that wasn't the genre had a diversity
problem black artists and women
musicians were rare in the scene travie
mccoy the front man of gym class heroes
said he struggled with finding
acceptance within the pop punk community
i was definitely a sore thumb at a lot
of shows in the early days fifi dobson a
pop punk singer said she dealt with
companies attempting to rebrand her as
an r b artist which she refused adoption
showed young black girls that they can
be angsty angry and alternative too
[Music]
what was that experience like it's a
just going back a little bit how did you
feel that the label tried to mold you
the one thing that actually was the red
flag was i think they thought it was a
compliment but they coined me as brandy
spears
and that really bothered me because
first of all i'm not
you know i love brandy love bernie but
i'm not i'm not them so basically it's
like boy she's brandy because she's
black
but she's got a poppy white voice so
she's brittany
and that's how they were selling me so
that it as young as i was i was about
15.
i knew
that felt weird that felt weird to
already be put in a box and put in a
category
and coined with a different name right
off the bat especially a box that is
just so not representative of yourself
do you feel that pop brock and pop punk
needed to be reinvented i'm happy pop
punk is back or pop rock i would say
both genres um
but i would also say that like
hell yeah why not
you know i think that we also went
through a crazy time
in the last few years
we need young people and anybody to come
out and be honest and shout how they
feel and
and be unapologetic because we've gone
through too much
and we were hit with so much in the last
three years that you know
we had to
come back musically
with you know
just honest raw emotion during the
pandemic tiktok began introducing pop
punk to a new generation and also
brought nostalgia to the genre's
long-term vans many 2000's pop punk
classics from bands like all time low
and paramore went viral on the app with
videos using their songs getting up to 3
million likes
with its growing community we're seeing
more diversity and tick-tockers are
utilizing hashtags like
black alt and hashtag alt poc which have
gained millions of views these include
bands like dwayne
magnolia park kenny hoopla cherum
and meet me at the altar
no one found out about us at all for
like four or five years because
we were over here like putting our music
on on spotify and all that we were kind
of just like screaming like hey we exist
but no one was hearing it so i'm
definitely sure that there's other bands
out there that are like that which i'm
glad our band getting recognition is
going to help them like know that they
have a space where they can reach out
and people actually hear them all these
bands are in their own little bubble
of pop punk if you look from the outside
it's all these white guys
like
talking about their girlfriends or
ex-girlfriends or yeah girlfriends they
never got whatever and then it's just
all the same stuff and then all of these
girls who are minorities are also in the
bubble but you don't see them because
there's not very many of them it's a
community that like we can't really
relate to sometimes so that's why we try
to make our own and i think that's
something that we do
as a band
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i think it's it's awesome but also
frustrating to be in that position of
being the first people are saying that
gen z is reinventing pop punk and do you
feel like that's the case it's so
strange to see how much like pop punk's
not dead that playlist on spotify has
changed because
originally that was
only bands only bands up there
but now like more than half of it is
solo artists who just have pop punk
instrumentals behind it so it's like
it's definitely changing and it's so
weird to see it
changed showed so drastically over the
last couple years what are some positive
reinventions that you're seeing happen i
do like that
some artists are starting to
sound more like the early 2000s like any
amanda bynes movie like soundtrack yes
that kind of that kind of sound is
coming back which is always so nostalgic
and it sounds so good gen z's disney
upbringing has also been a huge
influence in the revival today
they're influenced by disney stars like
demi lovato and miley cyrus who released
pop rock albums early on in their
careers
[Music]
while pop rock isn't the same as pop
punk
disney pop rock was many young girls
first introduction to alternative rock
and today we're seeing many young women
involved in the revival of pop punk can
you name the songs that you wrote for
these big disney stars um and how did
disney get their hands on the songs for
miley it was startled over for selena it
was a song called uh as a blonde round
and round was another one such a good
song
well i had an album called sunday love
that i wrote in
la there were songs that were on that
album that are on the album you can hear
my version of them that got picked up by
these girls
that disney influence still exists today
ex-disney star olivia rodrigo released a
pop punk inspired single that dominated
charts in 2021
[Music]
another young star in the pop punk
revival is willow who released her dance
track with my hair back in 2010
[Music]
willow's newest track transparent soul
has blown up on tick-tock and features a
heavy pop punk aesthetic
[Applause]
[Music]
has also influenced many of today's rap
stars artists like lil uzi vert and
juice world have cited pop punk bands as
major inspirations gen z has shown the
industry that they still want their pop
punk loud and catchy but for the leaders
of the scene to reflect the diverse
society we live in okay so wait our the
song yes let's talk about the song i
peep the the guitar progression is very
uh typical of you know pop punk yeah i
chose a very hooky like very basic
chord progression and it was fun nice
okay i'm going to play bass on it um
i gotta record some drums on it and it's
gonna be such a it's gonna be a real
small kid
[Music]
when you sing just let yourself go like
you know all the angst that you have
channel that and
[Music]
the concept i'm working with is calling
out the hypocrisy of people of society
[Music]
as always thanks for watching we want to
hear what your favorite pop punk tracks
are if you like you can submit a video
of you telling us your favorite songs at
the link in our description here are
your submissions from our last video
where we asked you what your favorite
backing vocals in a song are one of the
best backing vocals who that have been a
very very big inspiration to me has been
the d'angelo voodoo album really
anything on that album well we need to
talk about la la la and more
specifically their song color of the
pool janet jackson love from a feedback
album the whaler by a band called thrice
[Music]
you